so it turns out that it's not just
outsiders realizing that donald trump's
legal team
of course including rudy giuliani are
making him look like an idiot
we've now learned that donald trump's
inner circle has also been advising
donald trump
hey what rudy is doing is completely
embarrassing
the daily beast reports that members of
trump's inner circle
have been coming to him and saying sir
that's my ad-lib sir
he's making you look like an idiot
remember that just days prior
nbc reported trump was worried that his
legal team consisted of quote
fools that are making him look bad so it
does appear
that uh this is what donald trump is
being told but it's not stopping trump
trump continues tweeting about
these people he continues promoting
these harebrained voter fraud events
they did one yesterday
oh we covered a little bit of it live it
was rudy giuliani
and another trump attorney jenna ellis
in a room at a hotel
with some republican arizona lawmakers
bringing so-called witness after witness
to essentially say they didn't like the
way they were treated
as polling observers it was a bizarre a
dog and pony show
but trump keeps promoting it yesterday
trump tweeted trump legal team
in arizona and on oan now
big stuff enjoy this is not
because people aren't telling trump his
legal team
is making him look ridiculous trump is
being told that we now know
but he continues to promote these events
now there's a couple possibilities
one possibility is trump believes that
these
lawyers are making him look stupid but
he doesn't care
because it either keeps his name in the
news uh or it lets him fundraise
half of the money remember half of the
money fund raised for these
recounts and all this nonsense half the
money goes to
paying off his campaign debt so maybe
trump thinks it's worth it
maybe trump hears the people coming to
him and saying these lawyers are making
you look stupid
and he doesn't believe it that's still a
possibility that trump just doesn't
believe
that they're making him look dumb but
look at the list now rudy giuliani
hosted that ridiculous press conference
at a landscaping parking lot
in philadelphia weeks ago then rudy does
another press briefing in the basement
of a building somewhere in dc
that was the one where rudy's hair dye
made it look like he was bleeding out of
both ears
then rudy shows up at a hearing in
pennsylvania with republican state
lawmakers and spends
hours making unfounded claim after claim
about the election
but then trump calls into that one so he
couldn't have thought trump that is
trump couldn't have thought that one
made him look bad right i mean
he participated in it after all and then
yesterday trump also called into the
arizona
i i don't even like calling it a hearing
pr
event that rudy giuliani did and
meanwhile there are increasingly calls
for rudy giuliani himself to have his
legal license revoked
for continuing to file these bogus legal
challenges
all of which are getting thrown out the
real way
that trump made himself look like an
idiot is hiring rudy in the first place
to represent him in court and i've
talked about this before there's a
big difference between a tv lawyer and a
courtroom lawyer
rudy giuliani for a while was trump's tv
lawyer meaning he went on tv
and he advocated for the president but
he did it in a way that you wouldn't
actually do in a courtroom
so on tv rudy says voter fraud and he
says they have all this evidence and
proof of all these different things
in a courtroom rudy is really not
equipped to handle these cases
and he has been unable to even
successfully handle
a single one of these cases and the real
mistake
that trump made was thinking that rudy
could actually be his courtroom lawyer
when he is in
way over his head a narcissist never
makes the connection though that
listen trump hired rudy if rudy is the
idiot
and rudy is making trump look like one
as well
trump also must be the idiot for for
hiring rudy to begin with
the way trump and narcissists work is
any good
is solely their own doing but any bad
is solely the fault of others period
full stop and to some degree remember
that donald trump sent out sean spicer
i i want to say it was the first day of
trump's administration maybe it was the
second but i thought it was within hours
of the inauguration
trump sent out spicer his first press
secretary
to lie about the size of trump's
inauguration crowd size
that made trump look like an idiot and
it's been four more years of the exact
same stuff so yes
rudy is making trump look like a fool
but trump hiring rudy confirmed to us
that trump was the fool before rudy
filed even a single one of these
completely bogus lawsuits
again today a voter fraud hearing in
michigan
unclear as of this moment whether rudy
giuliani is participating
but would not be at all surprised to see
him there let me know on twitter
what do you think is the point of these
hearings what are they trying to get out
of them is it just raising money to pay
off campaign debt
is it something else i'm d pacman on
twitter let me know your thoughts
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people
quit smoking and vaping by offering a
clean
affordable nicotine alternative now
many of you know you've heard the
stories i've known several people in my
life who have struggled with quitting
smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical